こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
あのTwitterを見ているとアイス総選挙というものがありました
待って怖い見え、待ってやばい、見え待って見えそう見えそう 答えが見えそう...
アイス総選挙がどんなのかを教えて
なるほどなるほど...ま、簡単に言うと
テレビでアイスのランキングみたいなのがあって
ガチで決めたやつがあったんですけども
僕はあの本当に何も見ていません！
Twitterは何も見てないんですけども
そのアイス総選挙っていうすごいのがあってってことだけ知ってるんで
まぁ僕程のアイス大好き芸人となると
アイスの良さとか何やら色々わかるんで
ランキングっていうのを多分なんとなくそのわかるんですよ
アイス総選挙の結果を
僕は今日当てます！
アイス10位以内は全部買ってあるんで
多分1位から10位当てるとちょっと長くて
はじめ：そうです　後輩：おおーーー
はじめ：いやいやいや
後輩：え？
はじめ：待って、ほんとに待って待って
はじめ：待ってｗｗｗ　後輩：ｗｗｗ
はじめ：ちょっと10位から6位だけ聞いていい
後輩：なるほど
はじめ：10位と6位を先に聞いてイメージを膨らませて
はじめ：5位から　後輩：いやぁ
後輩：あぁ
はじめ：1位をちゃんと当てます順番をちゃんと
はじめ：10位から6位は
後輩：まず知ってる人もいるかもしんないんですけど
後輩：じゃベスト10から　はじめ：はい
後輩：ベスト10はロッテさんの
(編集中の)はじめ：
おっとみんなごめん紹介が遅れちまった
ここにいこいつは俺の後輩
かつて俺の動画で運動会のヨーイドンッバンッで起こされたかわいそうなやつだ
みんなよろしくな
(後輩改め)けんすけ：爽です
はじめ：爽がベスト10！？
はじめ：俺の中で1位だっ…なんでもないです
はじめ：ちょっと食べていいすか？
はじめ：まず10位の味を知ることから始めたい
はじめ：爽が10位ですか
けんすけ：まぁいっぱいあるすからねアイスなんて
けんすけ：1位っすよね　はじめ：この味は1位よ
けんすけ：じゃ第9位いきたいと思います
はじめ：はい
けんすけ：9位　はじめ：はい
はじめ：ま、ピノかーこれが9位か
はじめ：まぁピノも美味しいけど
けんすけ：まぁまぁまぁ
はじめ：ワンチャン俺の中では好き嫌いが分かれるアイスだと思ってるんだよな
けんすけ：まぁチョコレート嫌いって人もいますからね
はじめ：う〜ん
けんすけ：第8位
けんすけ：アイスの実です
はじめ：ふ〜ん
はじめ：俺これね食ったことないんだよねぇ
けんすけ：マジっすか
けんすけ：ぶどう味が8位らしいっす
はじめ：なんかオイラぶどう味を食うんだったら
はじめ：バニラアイスを食いたくなるんだよね
けんすけ：あーまぁまぁまぁまぁまぁまぁ
はじめ：うぇ
はじめ：こんなうまかった？待って本当に美味しい
けんすけ：いやいい無限、無限回収始まるよこれ
はじめ：ほんとに美味しいよ　待って待って
けんすけ：待って待って落ち着いて
けんすけ：落ち着いてあるあるまだまだ
はじめ：これ8位？　けんすけ：8位なんすよ
はじめ：お前ら頭おかしんじゃないのか
けんすけ：第7位パルムです
はじめ：パルムが7位？
けんすけ：パルム7位ですよ
けんすけ：俺結構びびったんすよ
はじめ：パルム1番美味しいのに7位なの？
けんすけ：パルム1番美味しいのに7位なんすよ
はじめ：すごいそんなことがあっていいのか
けんすけ：いや、パルムは実際1位
はじめ：ね、美味しいよね　けんすけ：うん
はじめ：高級な味がするんですよね　いただきます
はじめ：う〜ん　うまいなぁ
けんすけ：では第6位　はじめ：はい
けんすけ：これ6位　はじめ：いや…
けんすけ：これ6位って
はじめ：いやでも美味しいよ
けんすけ：いやでも、もっと上位きてもいいのかなって思ったちょっと
はじめ：まぁまぁまぁ　そういうことね
はじめ：ガリガリ君が6位か
はじめ：まぁけどこれ美味しんですけど
はじめ：何がすごいって値段が安い
はじめ：ほんとに値段の割にはほんとにめちゃくちゃ美味しい
はじめ：まぁ6位っちゃー6位なのかなってところではありますね
はじめ：食べます
はじめ：いただきます
はじめ：う〜ん夏にぴったりね
けんすけ：進んでない
けんすけ：ではベスト5のものを出すんでそっから順位を決めてください
はじめ：わかりました
はじめ：今食った10位から6位見た感覚で
はじめ：大体みんなのなんかわかったんで
けんすけ：おぉーぅ
けんすけ：では参ります
はじめ：おああー　おあー
はじめ：スーパーカップが2人もランクインしてる!?
けんすけ：そうなんですよ
はじめ：とりあえず俺が驚いたのは
けんすけ：そうなんです
はじめ：あっ
はじめ(心の声)：危ない俺は王だから
はじめ(心の声)：普段から
はじめ(心の声)：高いアイスを食べているのを
はじめ(心の声)：危うくみんなにバレるとこだった
はじめ(心の声)：危ない危ない
はじめ：フーーーーー
けんすけ：ハーゲンダッツ気になるところではあると思うじゃないすか
けんすけ：第11位ハーゲンダッツのクッキークリームなんすよ
けんすけ：クッキー&クリームなんすよ
はじめ：惜しいベスト10にギリ入れなかったってことか
けんすけ：12位があずきバー
はじめ：あー井村屋の
けんすけ：そう
けんすけ：13位がハーゲンダッツのバニラ
はじめ：うぉーうわっじゃハーゲンダッツ
はじめ(心の声)：おっと危ない危ない
はじめ(心の声)：俺は普段から
はじめ(心の声)：俺はハーゲンダッツのバニラとクッキークリームしか食わないから
はじめ(心の声)：ランクインした上位2つのハーゲンダッツは
はじめ(心の声)：ほぼ俺が買ってんだよなぁ
はじめ：うぅん続けてくれ
はじめ：この中から1位から5位を僕が当てます
はじめ：ちなみに豆情報なんですけども
はじめ：雪見だいふくは普段冬しか売ってないんですよ
はじめ：シーズン物のアイスだったんですけども
はじめ：最近全シーズン
けんすけ：おー
はじめ：常にお店に置かれるようになりました
はじめ：ちょっと味見してもいいですか
はじめ：ジャイアント食べないんだよね
けんすけ：えーそれめっちゃうまいっすよ
はじめ：俺これ食うんだったらパプリコ食っちゃうんだよね
けんすけ：いや
はじめ：カプリコか
けんすけ：いや、ナンセンスっすよそれは
はじめ：ほらうわっ、おーうあーーー
けんすけ：あーーー
はじめ：あああーもう
けんすけ：大丈夫大丈夫
はじめ：うーわぁ　え？
けんすけ：開けるとこ違うんすよ開けるとこ絶対違うんすよ
はじめ：あけくちって書いてありますね
はじめ：いやでも1番食ってるよ多分
けんすけ：うんー
けんすけ：はっはっはっはっはｗｗ
はじめ：口がおかしいから違うんだって
けんすけ：コガネムシなわけがない
けんすけ：コガネムシ逆に食ったんですか？
はじめ：いや、いや待て待て
けんすけ；ｗｗｗ
はじめ：いやうめーなでも、混ぜたらうまそうだなぁ
はじめ：3回までミス…許して
けんすけ：聞きましたかみなさん
けんすけ：3回…ちょちょちょｗｗ
けんすけ：マジで言ってるの？
はじめ：うん
はじめ：俺アイスの王様だから
けんすけ：絶対食うよ
はじめ：絶対食わない
けんすけ：絶対食う
けんすけ：絶対食うよーーーーーーー
はじめ：絶対食わないよーーーーーーー
はじめ：いきます　えっと…
けんすけ：はい
はじめ：え、え、え、え、え、えマジ？
はじめ：マジ？ほんと？
けんすけ：ほんとに　はじめ：マジ？
はじめ：やったー
はじめ：待ってふざけんなよ
はじめ：正解って聞こえたんだよぉ〜
けんすけ：はははははｗｗｗｗ
はじめ：正解って聞こえたじゃん
けんすけ：くしゃみ2連発
はじめ：1位からいきます
けんすけ：正解です
はじめ：正解？
けんすけ：スーーーーー正解
はじめ：Win?  けんすけ：Win
はじめ：clear?  けんすけ：success
はじめ：success?  けんすけ：year
はじめ：ﾊﾟｰﾌｪｸﾄｩ?  けんすけ：ﾝｰｰｰﾏﾝﾋﾟｰ
はじめ：あ、正解？
はじめ：おーよしよしよしよし
けんすけ：まぁまぁまぁまぁ
はじめ：よかったなんかアイスの王としての使命は果たせた
けんすけ：今のうち食っといた方いいですよ
はじめ：うん
けんすけ：今のうち食っといた方いいですよマジで
はじめ：やっぱあなたが1番なのね
はじめ：いや、むずくなってきたなぁ
はじめ：じゃちょっと攻めますね
けんすけ：はい
はじめ：攻めます
はじめ：ジャイアントコーンはすごいなさては
けんすけ：不？正解です
はじめ：なんて？　けんすけ：不？正解です
はじめ：せいかい？　けんすけ：正解
はじめ：サクセス？　けんすけ：イェース
はじめ：クリア？　けんすけ：イエス
はじめ：パーフェクト？
けんすけ：Congratulations
はじめ：イエーー
はじめ・けんすけ：ウエーーーイ
けんすけ：いやーこれは
はじめ：本当に合ってた？
けんすけ：合ってた合ってた合ってた合ってた
はじめ：よかったーでも、結局1位と2位は合ってたわけでしょ
けんすけ：そうそう
はじめ：おおおおお
はじめ：アイスの王様や
けんすけ：今のうち食っといたほうがいいですよ
はじめ：5(位)からいきます
はじめ：5位
はじめ：わからんなぁー(小声)
はじめ：ここら辺だと思うんだよなぁ
はじめ：スーパーカップのチョコチップかチョコモナカジャンボなんだよな
けんすけ：あと1回しかミスれないですよ
けんすけ：マジでアイス食えなくなるっすよ
けんすけ：ガチでアイス食えなくなるよマジで
けんすけ：あと3つ残ってるんすよ
はじめ：当てりゃいいんだろう当てりゃ
はじめ：任せろや
はじめ：となれば堂々と確実に取れそうなやつからいきます
けんすけ：はいはい
はじめ：ラストチャンスですね　いやーマジでむずいなぁ
けんすけ：はじめさんもうもうもうもうもうもうもう
けんすけ：もうもうもうもうもうもう
はじめ：うわあああああああああああああ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】